c'est acté la ville de saint germain en
laye et si ouailles cergy paris
université ont signé une convention pour
le lancement d'un nouveau campus
académique lundi 22 mars
il sera basé dans les locaux du campus
d'entreprise x bout je suis très content
parce que c'est l'une des ambitions que
l'on porte on est dedans on est dans un
département allaient qui vieillit un
petit peu un sens l'injurier et d'avoir
voilà tout ce dynamisme toute cette
jeunesse qui va venir à terme saint
germain sera une ville avec peut-être
5000 étudiants
voilà on a déjà sciences po on a déjà
beaucoup d'enseignement supérieur et on
renforce notre ambition universitaire
avec cette nouvelle arrivée ce
partenariat privilégié avec l'université
de cergy pontoise
ce futur pôle universitaire
internationale sera tournée vers le
design et l'ingénierie à terme entre 500
et 600 étudiants y évolueront sur ce
campus
on va déjà avoir un open design lab
c'est à dire un espace ouvert aux
étudiants de l'école de design de ses
ouailles tech mais aussi de sciences po
mais aussi de sup de vente et on va
pouvoir y venir développer ses idées
prototype est testé échanger créer
ensemble le projet démarré fin août 2020
n'a pas été ralenti par la crise
sanitaire les futurs locaux sont
actuellement en travaux pour une rentrée
des étudiants prévue en septembre 2021
[Applaudissements]